le château de La Coudre fait pe neuve
ancien siège de la Communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline le bâtiment va être réhabilité
en établissement d'hébergement pour
personnes âgées dépendantes un projet
lancé par la ville de Montini le
Bretonneux ça fait 6 ans que je me bat
sur ce dossier avec des haut et des bas
c'était pas c'est pas toujours évident
de réunir des partenaires de répondre à
un appel à projet d'être retenu de
trouver les financeurs c'est une grande
satisfaction mais il y a aussi un côté
très très émouvant lundi 13 juin le
maire de la commune a posé la première
pierre en compagnie du président du
conseil départemental pierre-bédier le
futur établissement du groupe coriant
accueillera 88 résidents des travaux
commencés en avril avec la construction
d'une extension une nouvelle vie pour ce
château du 19e siècle à l'intérieur on
donc on réaménage une partie des locaux
administratifs et communs à
l'établissement et dans la partie neuve
F on constru les chambres et les salons
les unités Alzheimer notamment le nouvel
éepad sera situé au cœur du parc de La
Coudre proche des commerces et du public
les personnes âgées adorent les parcs
adorent les jardins et là on a un
environnement naturel nos résidents vont
pouvoir aller se promener dans le parc
et rencontrer d'autres personnes donc
pour le maintien de du lien social c'est
extrêmement important coût total des
travaux 8 millions d'euros le projet
représente également la création de 50
un emploi l'ouverture est prévue pour
fin